brightens weathers in Kansas City hi
Brighton how are you I'm doing well
thanks for taking my call sure what's up
so my wife and I we're debt-free and
we're working on getting our emergency
fund saved up I just recently started
listening to the show and really
enjoying it so my question is my wife is
kind of she's kind of of the mindset
that if we have to take on debt in the
future she's okay with that and I'm
really I don't like that and obviously I
don't want to go and bed it all in the
future so what would be your advices to
getting her on the same page as me and
resolving to never go into debt you know
other than like a house mortgage if it's
possible oh it's possible um
the lots of people do the question is
what is the best path the shortest path
to wealth is it through the debt went
use of debt or not and it's a pretty
simple equation then isn't it and so
what what she's saying is oh well we
might have to if we want a nice car we
might have to because that's what
everybody does and that's how these
people sound right and but what she's
really saying is is that she thinks
she's never going to have anything nice
if she doesn't do that or she's never
going to win if she doesn't do that or
we're never going to financially succeed
if we don't go into debt and that's just
not the truth the truth is the if you
live like no one else later you get to
live and give like no one else and so
the process of convincing someone of
that in a if they're willing to listen
and talk about it it is just to go okay
what is the shortest path to wealth and
if borrowing money is the shortest path
to wealth and the most effective and the
highest probability of retaining the
wealth then then you borrow money but
the truth is we know otherwise and
that's what is led you away from them
because you don't want the risk of the
payments you don't want the risk of the
foreclosure the reap
position on you you don't want to deal
with all of that and you know and you
don't believe it's the shortest path to
wealth that's really you know it's the
shortest path to looking wealthy when
you're broke a lot of people look like
they've got money but they're broke I
have no net worth or a negative net
worth and and they're stressed out and
freaked out because they thought well
the only way I'm ever going to have
something the only way I'm ever going to
enjoy my life the only way I'm ever
going to dot dot dot is to borrow into
it and really what that's saying is
you're surrendering the best in order to
get the okay the enemy of the best is
not the bad the enemy of the best is the
okay okay okay when you just settle for
okay
that's the biggest time people miss out
on the best so I'm not positive how to
convince her of that in her situation
but I think at the core of her thinking
we might borrow money someday is that's
kind of like saying either a we might
give up in our in our track to win or B
I don't believe that being debt-free is
the best way to build wealth but if you
believe that then you stay away from
debt if it's the best way to have a
quality life financially I stay away
from it
you know if Bears bite I don't put my
hand in a bear cage you know it's you
know but you have to believe that it's
you're acting on your belief and so
you've got to talk it back through that
way and see if you can land on the same
page whether I sure hope you can because
there's a high correlation between
people that are on the same page and
those that win financially hey guys
thanks for watching if you enjoyed this
video click the subscribe button to get
the latest content and check out these
other great clips from the show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]